un déconfinement à deux vitesses c'est
ce qu'a choisi le gouvernement chilien
un plan cinq étapes
baptisé pas à pas est appliqué à des
rythmes différents selon les régions les
quartiers à santiago depuis cette
semaine les terrasses de plusieurs
quartiers chics de la capitale peuvent
enfin rouvrir une bonne nouvelle pour ce
restaurateur fermé depuis plusieurs mois
nous avions peur de rouvrir parce que
nous n'avions pas d'espacés extérieurs
nous pensions que nous ne pourrions pas
gagner d'argent que c'était plus
rentable de rester fermés mais la
municipalité a pris une excellente
initiative et nous a permis d'utiliser
une partie des trottoirs pour augmenter
le nombre de tables changement de décor
dans ce quartier encore strictement
confiné de l'est de l'agglomération de
santiago
ici à l'eau hermida la crise sanitaire a
aussi réveillé un drame que le chili
croyait avoir éradiqué la fin pour
tenter d'y remédier les soupes
populaires se sont multipliés comme
celle des guerras les guerrières créé
par neuf femmes
chaque jour elle livres 175 repas des
habitants frappée par la fin c'est ce
qui nous pousse nous et pas seulement
moi être ici tous les jours à leur
donner de la nourriture un repas correct
a essayé de faire de notre mieux alors
donné de quoi se nourrir et pas
seulement de l'eau potable je ne sais
pas si on pourra leur donner quelque
chose demain alors si on peut le faire
maintenant ont donné leur de la
nourriture digne de ce nom quelque chose
de chaud cela fait cinq mois que je n'ai
rien reçu mais je n'ai eu que ce qu'il
me donne rien d'autre parce qu'il me
fournissent de la nourriture chaque jour
chaque jour du pain chaque jour dégoûté
a pour nos enfants
selon les associations caritatives o
manca de chansons populaires fonctionne
dans tous santiago où vivent plus de 7
millions de personnes
ces derniers jours le gouvernement a
levé l'interdiction de voyager à
l'intérieur du pays en raison de la
stabilisation du taux d'occupation des
hôpitaux
et des décès dus aux coronavirus le
couvre-feu national entre 22h et 5h du
matin est lui toujours en vigueur